suddenly people are speaking of a
comeback in U.S politics but the
question is did he ever really go away
we're talking of course about Donald
Trump who very reluctantly left the
White House after voters made Joe Biden
America's 46th president but Trump never
accepted defeat and there's a growing
feeling that he's moving back center
stage on a mission to recapture the
presidency and his animosity towards his
Democrat successor is as toxic as ever
so on to the point we ask retaliation
and revenge can Biden Escape Trump's
shadow
foreign
[Music]
from the German Marshall fund who argues
that Trump remains a weak candidate but
a trumpist Republican party certainly
poses a very real threat to American
democracy
also with this is Anika Brock Schmidt
who is an author and journalist
specializing on the Christian right in
America among other things and she
believes that Trump has got the
Republican Rank and file in the palm of
his hand add to that the Christian
rights infrastructure and democracy is
taking a pound Inc and a very warm
welcome too to Matthew College Nick
Chief Europe correspondent at Politico
and Matthew says Trump has virtually no
chance of winning again America has
learned its lesson
yeah fascinating comment there uh good
comments all free thank you for being
here today Rachel let me begin with you
we're clearly going to focus on Donald
Trump today the question is a possible
comeback in the making do you sense that
he is once again sort of gearing up to
do battle with his enemies
um definitely battle with his enemies
and um you know talking about Doom and
Gloom and complaining about the
president and all of the mistakes the
president making I mean this was already
during the Obama term if we remember
back to the original Trump so he's he's
not going anywhere he's gonna you know
stay in the Limelight he's gonna keep up
this narrative he's going to harass Joe
Biden as much as possible and he
probably will also run
um or if not just collect a lot of money
in the meantime has already indeed yeah
yeah he says we're going to take America
back so what does that mean what do uh
what what what are the what's he going
to do with America yes that is a good
question what did he do the time before
uh you know he's he's going back to some
fantasy time where you know everyone was
conservative there weren't these you
know weird new people and everyone spoke
English I don't know I mean um you know
what what we got was chaos as Matt said
um you know when he was actually in
charge
um but that's not the point the point is
this kind of narrative of fear and gloom
and doom and that he's very good at
Annika does Donald Trump have a credible
political agenda or is it all about
Trump is it all about the man himself oh
I think for him it's all about Trump but
I think he has a sort of intuitive knack
for weaponizing both Christian
nationalism and these sort of racist
undertones that are part of it and I
think he's managed to do that
um less codified and more open than any
other Republican president or candidate
his dad unprecedented yeah and he's had
a lot of success with it and I think the
Republican party as a whole has realized
that backing Trump is the only way that
they can have political success within
their own party and they definitely seem
to be sticking to it the weekly German
news magazine Spiegel which is pretty
influential here in Germany says that he
is the most dangerous pensioner in the
world what do you think of that comment
well I think it's fairly accurate um and
I think I mean he hasn't announced yet
but because you know he still draws
money from the packs and as soon as he
will announce his candidacy he won't be
able to do that anymore
but I think if he runs he won't have any
opposition from other candidates in the
party and I think he is on a clear track
to um yeah endanger American democracy
and the Republicans seem to be backing
him
you agree with him Matthew no I don't
agree at all in fact and I I don't think
that he's been particularly successful
with it to be honest because he lost the
last election he didn't just lose the
last election his party lost control of
Congress at the last election and they
also lost the midterm elections before
that and it has become clear that any
candidate even though he has control of
the party that's true but for the
candidates themselves who were running
they have to swear allegiance to Trump
but at the same time they have to
distance themselves and we saw this in a
very important election last week in
Virginia where the the candidate sort of
professed to be a trump supporter but he
didn't want Trump anywhere near the
campaign and the reason he won was by
focusing on local issues and uh not you
know embracing Trump in a big way and I
think this is what we're going to see in
the the coming elections that people
will not just disavow Trump but they're
also not going to claim you know a
particular affinity for him in the way
that we've seen in in recent years and
the reason is is that especially in
urban areas where Republicans have lost
a lot in recent years in order to win
Suburban voters you need to show that
you're not particularly trumpist and if
the Republicans don't do that you know
then they're doomed in the long term
Rachel you're nothing
yeah I mean this part I do agree with I
think I think Trump's control of the
Republican party is very problematic I
think the state of the Republican party
where you know more and more people are
signing up to the big lie
um this is this is dangerous this is
really a problem but I don't think
exactly with signing up to the big line
the big lie that Trump won the election
in 2020 that it was kind of a new
foundational but is it more and more
people or is it the same people no well
I mean it's it's a much too strong
majority of the problem party it should
be five people
yeah I mean this is 93 of Democrats say
he lost 70 percent but he did lose so 93
are talking facts and 70 are sharing a
lie publicly I mean this is a problem it
shouldn't be 70 it should be ten percent
when it's 70 that's a problem for the
party but I agree with Matthew Trump is
not a good candidate Trump trump will
probably lose okay uh one thing the most
or at least many observers agree on is
that there is at the moment a distinct
Buzz around Donald Trump and he is
apparently beginning to look as if he is
already on the campaign Trail
we will make America proud again
we will make America safe again and we
will make America great again God bless
you Donald Trump hits the campaign Trail
taking any Center Stage wherever he can
along the way the question of whether he
will run for president again in 2024 is
more of a rhetorical one for him who
will that be I wonder
thank you
and Donald Trump is gaining momentum
Republicans have reclaimed governorships
in crucial U.S states
at his current hideout in Palm Beach
Florida Trump is busy erecting a
fortress of money power influence anyone
who wants to be in a position of power
within the party is thinking of joining
forces with the ex-president here and
anyone who opposes him could be stopped
cold in their tracks at the same time
Trump is making sure that the election
laws are changed to favor Republicans
after Facebook and Twitter deleted his
accounts he continued spreading the
toxic fairy tale of the stolen 2020
election on his own social media channel
titled truth that election will go down
as the crime of the century and our
country has been
his supporters believe it and trumpism
apparently refuses to die
is Donald Trump still a threat to
democracy
[Music]
well that is the big question is he a
threat to democracy especially in an
alliance with the Christian right I
think he definitely is but I also have
to say I think any candidate that even
if it wasn't Trump that would be backed
by the religious right in the U.S which
has in a way become synonymous with the
Republican Party
um as of the late 90s basically we can
see that that they've taken over sort of
the the base ranks of the party and they
run the ship now and the religious right
was founded in the 60s with a clear goal
of establishing minority rule because
they knew that they couldn't win
majorities in elections anymore and so
it's not necessarily a question of
whether or not a majority of Americans
want him as a candidate or even as a
president but the question of whether or
not the Republican party will be able to
suppress the vote for example in certain
States because yes Biden won the popular
vote with you know buy quite a lot
however when we look at the Electoral
College it was quite narrow
so it's always narrow in the Electoral
culture yeah but if one of the big two
big parties is
um really pushing for a whole new set of
motor suppression laws and targeting
specific States then that's a problem
because it came down to a few ten
thousand votes in I think three states
so that's not a big margin if you're
looking to to sway
um sway the vote just for a second
Matthew I'd like to talk about Trump the
man because I mean he this is somebody
his driving force his resentment in many
ways he says that more or less himself
he says he his aim is to get even with
people if they screw you screw them back
10 times as hard that is the logic of
the mob is it not yeah it is but this is
how he came to power this is why people
love him and this is the exact same
rhetoric that we've always heard from
him so none of this is really new but
this is also why his approval ratings
are below 40 percent he's not getting
more popular I mean you say there's a
lot of Buzz around there's always been a
lot of Buzz around him I would argue
there's less Buzz around him now than
there was a few years ago because he's
not on Twitter he's not on Facebook and
when was the last time anyone here was
on truth I mean you know truth is not a
a social media outlet that has a lot of
users to be honest and so he has lost
the direct connection that he had to
many voters with Twitter in particular
and I think that's really uh hurting him
because he has difficulty maintaining
the level of Buzz that he that he had as
as president
I'm still surprised because I don't know
if I've been reading the different
different American news from you in the
past
I have to I'll confess to that but just
as one example here David from I mean
he's a conservative he's a former speech
writer to George W bush and I found him
saying that he that people in America
should get prepared for malicious
destructiveness that is coming their way
that's surely not what Americans want
well I think that people like it's just
destructive and others it is it is
destructive but they want people they
want to Rally the opposition again and
that's why I think that if Trump does
run that's the best thing that the
Democrats could hope for if they want to
maintain control of the white house
because as soon as Trump is the
candidate they are going to completely
mobilize their own people we saw this in
California in an important election a
couple of months ago now for the
governorship there where the incumbent
was a Democrat he was challenged by a
recall effort and he ended up
remaining in office because all of the
anti-trump forces came out in large
numbers and I think you're going to see
that in the next presidential election
as well two agree with that Rachel that
Trump is good for the Democrats
yeah I think I think he is because
um you know with Trump people know what
they're getting he has his message and
it's a pretty unpopular message except
for
um the base so other candidates I think
could be you know like a youngkin can in
Virginia who just won the Virginia race
that is more dangerous someone who can
take you know mention Trump enough take
enough of his messages to win his voters
and yet be a little bit less you know a
little bit less racist a little bit less
problematic a little bit less erratic so
I think there would be other candidates
that could be more dangerous well nobody
has forgotten January the sixth earlier
this year when a violent mob apparently
incited by Donald Trump himself attacks
the capital building in Washington and
in doing so
effectively attacked the very Foundation
of American democracy Annika did Trump
uh was Trump responsible for this
colossal attack on American democracy
was he the controlling function there
I'm not sure if he was the controlling
function
um I think he definitely did incite it I
think the impeachment trial showed that
very clearly however as we find out more
day by day we also have to acknowledge
that there is a network of the political
and religious right which in a way is
anonymous by now which was very involved
with organizing this January 6 rally
which then led to the storming of the
capital and this is something that I
don't think we should underestimate
because the mobilizing power of the
religious right
is often overlooked and with a party
that has clearly set their goal has set
their eyes on minority rule
a state and Nationwide Network that can
mobilize people in you know the key
areas is really important
would you say Rachel that uh January the
6th we it appears to to me to have been
effectively like a dress rehearsal for
even more profound challenges to
American democracy it seems to be like a
watershed moment that's why I come back
to it yeah I mean it's hard to say
January 6 was was shocking
um it was you know very problematic we
should definitely take it seriously but
you know we have had a history a long
history of you know sort of armed
violence attacks against the government
you know there was the bombing of the
FBI in the 90s from a militia Group
which is you know so it's a very similar
type of picture you know the difference
being of course that you didn't have a
president
um you know in inciting and organizing
um back then right so the difference is
how how it's being endorsed by
mainstream political forces that's the
problem and um I'm more worried about
that than I am about you know too many
people who are interested in violence
and have the weapons to frankly I mean
it's also scary but I I I'm not sure
that people have had those for a while
you said earlier that Americans have
learned their lesson what lesson have
they learned well I think by looking at
these pictures people think like Jesus
Christ this I don't want this to happen
again I mean not the Bible Thumpers but
most people would say this is not the
United States that I want to live in and
uh I think that in the next election
campaign if the Democrats just show this
video uh that's all they need to do to
win because it'll remind people of what
happened on January 6 and I would just
add though that this is a a small
minority of uh even the Republican Party
in the U.S I mean we're talking about a
couple of thousand people here in a
country who are flying across the
country by the way to get to Washington
some of them uh including the guy with
the Buffalo horns from my home state of
Arizona uh but you know it's a country
of 350 million I think now so you know
if the president of the United States is
calling his you know most loyal
supporters to Washington to a rally and
that you know sort of encouraging them
to do something like this it's not that
surprising I think it's it's obviously
very worrying I find more worrying that
this the complete Security breakdown uh
that day and that they they didn't
manage to you know it's never been
properly addressed security lines well I
think their investigations into that
into that now and and why that why that
failure uh happened but uh that their
you know these whack jobs out there you
know wanting to do that that doesn't
surprise me at all and I think this has
always been you know a a potent
um sort of vain in American politics
that you know you have a a lot a very
strong undersswell of of frustration
that you know kind of comes out every
once in a while okay let's just change
the little the the mood just a little
bit and go back to Joe Biden he is after
all the president
and he got off to a pretty reasonable
start in office encouraging the
impression that he might be able to
bring some sort of unity to a divided
America now however the Biden presidency
appears to be faltering
for U.S allies the election of Joe Biden
seemed like a godsend with him and vice
president Kamala Harris many hoped a
sense of reliability would return to
Washington America is on the move again
these hopes were partially dashed
Trump's announcement of troop withdrawal
from Afghanistan was chaotically
executed by Biden without consulting U.S
allies
Biden lets an Armament deal with France
fall through and upsets Europeans in the
process
the refugee situation on the border with
Mexico remains dramatic and Biden's
efforts to contain the coronavirus
pandemic are not making enough of an
impact images like this one of him
nearly falling asleep at the
international climate change conference
are welcome fodder for his critics
Biden presented himself as a dynamic
go-getter after the election now he's
showing signs of weakness
can he and his team turn things around
okay Anika let's go with that question
can he and his team turn things around
but I would say the clock is certainly
ticking I think the Democrats
um basically have until the midterms to
turn things around so he's just passed
this major infrastructure deal which is
a big win you have to say because it's
um you know the biggest infrastructure
deal that's been passed in uh you know
decades however I'm not sure if the
effects of that will you know become
apparent to the population quickly
enough now the pandemic there there's
been a bit of there was a bit of good
news with fisa allowing the vaccination
of 5 to 11 year olds which is good
however I think
um the odds are stacked against the
Democrats in a way because again they
only have one year left to pass
significant other reforms concerning the
justice system and voting rights in
order to prevent uh Republican attacks
on voting rights and the justice system
many say Joe Biden simply isn't up to
the job are you among the doubters
I mean I think he's he's got a pretty
difficult hand that he's dealing with
here I mean you know and lots of things
that the president gets blamed for are
not really his fault I mean we were all
happy to blame Trump when the pandemic
had you know the president has limited
control over these things even when he
takes it seriously he still can't force
everyone to get um you know vaccinated
um he can't control Global Supply chains
he can't control the you know
um holes in the labor market he can't
control gas prices think people think
that he can and they're very upset about
the you know gas prices that are double
what they used to be under Trump these
are all factors adding to his
unpopularity
um I think infrastructure will help I
mean this was also we've you know been
debating this big package for weeks now
and this was frustrating that even with
the majority they couldn't pass anything
so I I think he's he has achieved a lot
I mean infrastructure Trump promised
infrastructure and couldn't deliver it
so Biden has actually delivered a lot
um but it's it's you know these are
troubling times it's not easy job right
now you agree Matthew it's not it's I
mean this these are really I mean why
don't the Americans cutting some slack
that's that's the feeling I get when I
you know as I look at it was it was ever
that's every president goes through this
and if you look go back look at Ronald
Reagan after he was in office for a year
he wasn't nearly as popular as he was in
in subsequent years
um the same thing with Obama I mean this
is always kind of a difficult period for
every new president and I'm not here as
a partisan for for Joe Biden I would say
though that I think he is qualified for
the job to your question I mean clearly
I mean he was vice president he was
Senator for a number of years he knows
the system
um he's clearly qualified he's a bit old
and I think that we're seeing you know
some of the problems associated with
with his age in terms of his stamina and
so forth but
um you know the question is
will Americans give him credit for these
programs that have recently passed I
mean it's a trillion dollars in
infrastructure spending it's going to
take a while before they get the shovels
in the ground on that but there are
other
infrastructure-like programs that he's
trying to get past in Congress and
there's a lot of you know kind of
discussion about that there and I think
that might might lift people's Spirits
at the same time with inflation over six
percent
um you know who knows I mean but there's
a long time to go here I mean I would
expect that he would lose the midterm
elections next year that the Democrats
would and then you have this sort of
gridlock situation but again if Trump is
the candidate in 2024 you know I think
Biden's chances are looking pretty good
okay we're running out of time Veronica
there is one thing that interested me
very much you write about how the
Republicans uh winning the game if I
might put it like that by setting
rhetorical traps for the Democrats yeah
I mean um I think we could see that in
Virginia with a youngkin as a basically
a trumpist candidate who doesn't look
trumpist who doesn't sound trumpist but
who effectively you know suppose the
same
um the same policies and we can see that
with sort of propped up debates like
over critical race Theory which was
generated by conservative activist who's
said so publicly that they mean to you
know set CRT as the new device then what
CRT is just to do critical rights theory
is a theory that is taught at a law
school level about how systemic racism
is inherent to the American justice
system
Junkin and his fellow Republicans are
claiming that that is taught in schools
to indoctrinate children and it's
basically used as a buzzword for
anything that deals with anti-racist
measures even though that is not
necessarily what CRT is but it's a new
buzzword and Democrats don't know how to
deal with that they don't yeah but this
is identity politics I mean you can call
it CRT you can call it yeah and it's
always great
but Trump didn't invent this they didn't
need Trump to come up with the CRT issue
this is the type of thing that has been
a Mainstay of Republican tactics for a
long time and it works and it worked for
Junkin and why did it work for Junkin in
Virginia because his opponent the
Democrat the incumbent was uh sorry it
wasn't the incumbent but he's a previous
governor there he ran against Trump and
he tried to say if you elect youngkin
you're going to get Trump and voters
were more focused on local issues so
bringing Trump up in these local
elections is not going to work but a
national election because Trump isn't on
the ballot there but when Trump actually
is on the ballot you know I think that's
where they're going to have a problem
okay we've got to go back to where we
started Rachel uh can uh can Biden step
out of Donald Trump's Shadow can he win
the next election if he's up against
Trump that's the question I mean Biden
defeated Trump uh already once I think
he can defeat Trump again but he's not
going to get rid of Trump trump is going
to be a feature of his entire uh
candidacy I think or his entire
presidency this we know so he can't get
rid of trump but I think he has good
chances of defeating Trump again
I think it's more difficult I think uh
systemic attacks by Republicans will
make it more difficult for any
Democratic candidate in the future one
final word of wisdom well I don't think
it has to be bad necessarily I think
anybody who runs against Trump will win
because people are too scared of what
another Trump presidency would mean okay
we've been looking at Trump versus Biden
where's it all leading thanks very much
for joining us if you've enjoyed the
show as much as I have come back next
time until then bye bye and cheers
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]